venti ragazzi pervenute che sono video
sono file di soldati su quel
mattacchione di giochi ho chiamato fuga
ai ragazzi che cadono dai ragazzi
partenza andiamo su nights with perfetto
partiamo subito sulla lotta alla mafia
che nello scorso video nell'uscita solo
una che era appunto si legge si chiamava
meno male che almeno in questo video
partiamo con le mappe nuove raga almeno
quello allora cnai fever è molto bella
ragazza che è tipo una roba medievale
carina molto figo lo avete già visto
ovviamente se avete già visto la live
parto soluzione valida due però il video
ancora nell'uscita ragazzi molto
importante farvela vedere è molto più
facile tutto a posto ragazzi per carità
dicendo che è molto più difficile di
quello che sembra st [ __ ] mappa
perché è molto bella visivamente ma è
molto difficile da giocare e piena di
ostacoli ragazzini mai sottovalutarla
ne ho risolto perfetto vai vai vai
veloce che sony sia non so come ho fatto
a salvarmi non me lo chiedete non ne ho
idea via via via via via via viazza no
ti prego non è vero ce l'ho fatta non ci
voglio credere
secondo secondo lo primo passo e forse
non si fosse pazzo il pazzo
va bene ragazzi allora la prima
l'abbiamo fatta sono già soddisfatto che
era exige ecco la nuova buona nuova
due nuove 2 su 2 cioè l'anno scorso vide
uscita solo cosa si dei sì alle sue
strutture ma che culo c'è un silenzio si
legge di spostare le cose meno male
meno male perché me lo vediamo tutte le
mappe nuove poi manca solo quella del
dominicano che si chiama quando vedi
spostarle cose arrivare alla fine che
maledetti e quella che esco meno fare
tra due ragazzi faccio vedere un po di
tattiche per ex seal che ho appurato dal
dalla live che ho già giocato un bel po
io gli faccio vedere tanti adesso siamo
in 20mila persone se non mi grappa te
grazie
siamo in 20mila quindi non è proprio
semplice farà vedere adesso perché la
partita è molto varia in base al fatto
che siamo in 2000 però esistono delle
tattiche molto interessanti che sono
stare nel mezzo
no prossimi gravate io mi ammazzo
ragazzi cioè non mi dovete gravare i
tassi del grave bisogna infilare nel
deretano ragazzi importante questo e
segnatevelo quando si porta alle uova
sempre andare alla squadra che sta
perdendo la somma per l'eni non è detto
questa la squadra perdente papa niente
che quella che ha meno uova e si
lanciano le uova fuori quindi come i
next crumble ma le uova lanciate così
guardate bilanciate e poi togliete il
tasso di kraft è il luogo il personaggio
lo lancia proprio come se fosse basket
che vedete è molto importante questa
cosa qua ragazzi rilanciate le uova così
salite di sopra lancia volevo la parola
del sabato dai blu ragazzi perché non
sono i rossi che sta prendendo però
andare a sabotare il gruppo perché io
stavo salutando la squadra vincente
sabotare la squadra vincente non serve a
nulla
e come se tu non stessi giocando tanto
loro vincono a prescindere mi voleva
portare gli altri ragazzi guardaroba
perfetto no mancano ci volete suscitato
chiama a buttarlo fuori o che abbia
vinto sabotare sempre la squadra che sta
perdendo ragazzi avete capito la tattica
ha date sulle uova e le buttate fuori
proprio come se si stesse lanciando in
nba trans trans trans bam bam e volgare
ma veramente assurdo raga ma stanno
cielo tutte le mappe nuove perché cuoco
ragazzi nello scorso video era uscito
solare sono solo le vecchie adesso solo
quelle non aver ricevuto che ai ragazzi
vuoi guys va bene allora cerchiamo di
farla al meglio perché è molto difficile
anche con questa bella secondo me i
ragazzi a fare il mio
questa è la mappa più difficile questa è
la tappa più difficile in assoluto
perché bisogna anche la parsi per per
salire tiri club aree da solo
no no è veramente difficile ragazzi che
la spingo pro
maledetta stampa perché gli altri ti
spingono il coach e ti spingono mentre
ti arrampichi e non riesce a raffica ma
che roba
porca vacca la pergola per le cose così
aperto perché se a roma la gente è
perfetto
ho fatto uno come trampolino perfetto
vai vai vai meraviglioso direttamente a
quell'altra perfetto giocato morto
emilio stati vani che salivo
meraviglioso raga non ci crea volo
giocata benissimo giocando benissimo ok
allora 12
manca solo questo saldo finale ha detto
no però funzionano al vicinato che è
stato grazie 0 è questo il problema ci
sto gioco c'è nelle mappe nuove che gli
altri possono avvantaggiarsi anche
cercando di a vantaggio di avvantaggiare
se stessi però non è scarsa o ragazzi
perché sono leggenda da un casino
ovviamente miniato al monte in o jap
solano andrebbero bene job sola un che
va bene va bene frigo si guarda
l'espresso è però dai che sfiga o vedi
che l'unica piattaforma che rimane
quella gialla laggiù dove lo prima
commette anche adulti di fila raga
speriamo allora speriamo che dall'ultima
gialle in alto a sinistra
se cade l'ultima in alto a sinistra sono
messo benissimo larga perché quale
mancano 2 e posso prendere tempo no
infatti perso e non mi conviene più
ormai ragazzi montarmi perché se mi
butto adesso aveva parte che sono i
duemila qui che diventano poi draghi non
sempre ma è se mi fossi buttato non
avrebbe avuto senso comunque a
prescindere perché probabilmente sarei
caduto perché ormai la lancetta è troppo
veloce la goty butti all'inizio non tifo
di più allora adesso l'unico gioco che
faccio e prendere tempo e provare se
riesco a gravare l'unicorno perché qui
non c'è niente l'unicorno pro voglio
vincerla questa
madonna è caduto tizio è caduto proprio
lui posso provare a foster locus
decisissimo ragazze grabar con no perché
se programma col club a lui per libica
non lo faccio finché non è necessario
sono caduti
raga marca puro v11 v12 grappolo
grappolo
lo chiamano campo nello g no club
tigrato tigrato tigra forse meno male
non si voglio crede
meno male meno male perché poteva
decidere di tra farmi due poi dopo su
minori vedere intanto devo fare mi
dimentico ha tra l'altro ragazzi ho
davanti una che si chiama chiara luce va
bene ragazzi ho viste e vabbè dopo
dicendo chi installa bakwa nella nuova
si sono modificate hanno tolto le cose
che spinge non so se l'hanno alternò mi
sa che alternarli dove abbiamo ragazzi
tecnologiche fa veramente statuto screw
dell'area da ridere cioè nel senso che
faccio pena che hanno aggiunto quelle
robe lì che girano che prima non c'erano
di base già da solo quelle robe li
spinge meno male perché preferisco
questi che almeno sei più perché negli
altri di aspettare gli altri invece in
questi poi fa da solo quella nuova
quella nuova quella nuova proprio lui si
deve niente o porca vacca io voglio
farmi forte fare le mappe nuove dammi un
bel 3 dammi un bel due donne un belluno
e vinciamo st [ __ ] partita ok
vai tu in questa noto ragazzi solita
tattica ragazzi inutile si per chi non
lo sapesse bisogna saltare libertino
sapete tipo io noto stare al centro
ragazzi continua gira brutti pezzenti
comunque raga l'importante è stata
inventata da un lato metà dall'altra
esami svantaggio però facciamo pagare io
non ho preso ancora un certo 15 12 bravo
lo zio da che significhiamo citiamo
tutto quello che il nostro togliti rosso
schifoso
togliti c'è niente non si dove domanda
ecco quattro perfetto meno male che mi
sta venendo il signor sono ragazzi meno
malagrotta
allora il mio organismo decidere di non
stare singhiozzare proprio nel momento
della partita fifty fortis e ex miss
fissate nel suo my boys ma da lei rossi
hanno fatto 66 raghe tantissimo trova
essa con mamma mia
raga proviamo la seconda vittoria
proviamo la seconda vittoria di fila
se usciva col mondo e me ne andavo però
è riuscito a essere un meno male però la
seconda vittoria ad a mentre da miu 2
dammi un 1 levati dalle palle no no no
no no però non vi dovete fare una
bollare ti ammazzo ti ammazzo io faccio
vedere io mi butto giù insieme alla
vostra sting maledetta allora allora
ragazzi posso esporre un problema perché
ancora velocità che secondo la tua sito
nei video espongo un problema fateci
caso
guardate quanto corre la gente io non ho
capito perché la gente con la nuova
season ha iniziato a correre se ci fate
caso in crisi la gente corre cosa
correte perché la gente guardava di
comune che ti corrono sotto perché
perché la gente si è messa a correre in
ex amon non correva nessuno è come se
l'update e corse la cena nuova avesse
fatto correre la gente ma senza un
motivo
non c'è un motivo non ricorrono a caso
la gente con la casa non correre lo
capisci che sei corica diavolo chi lo
capisce
cioè la gente non ha capito sta roba la
gente la gente continua a correre ma non
serve a niente correre concorrenti o
guardano tutti sti spazi quanto è
accaduto è caduto però saltare stato non
venire la meta non beni ed a me non me
li a rompermi le palle amen
c'è di tutto c'è un miliardo di opel a
perfetto non viene da me problema che le
sue pisco le piattaforme porco demonio
lo finite demandare alla meta finale
larga morga forse riesco a buttarmi sul
viola qua fermi un attimo ci provo si
vabbè guadagno niente e poi alla fine
prova bebo
no no no no non è vero bonora cam e non
correte non correte non corre modulnova
marzo si sono mangiati si sono mangiati
venire qua no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]